[Musique]
représente beaucoup de choses presque
tout m'aev c'est elle qui m'a appris
à peut-être mon métier
d'ambulancier à 3 ans elle
m'emmenait chercher les biberon à
versaill dans dans son ambulance j'ai
fait 43 ans au SM de pré donc
voilà ta cétait une française mais une
chrétienne
donc avec ma grand-mère et ben elles
sont elles ont été dans les dans les
maisons qui étaient vide pour récupérer
des des vêtements d'homme les amener à
la à l'église et là les prisonniers
changeaient et et pouvait repartir
s'évader des prisons allemandes des du
camp prisonniers
allemand au départ elle avait du mal à
le transmettre parce que mal
heureusement son frère aîné lui n'est
pas revenu des qu concentration il a été
pendu à no GAM je crois que c'était 8 f
8 février 45 elle entendait parler
allemand elle avait les poils qui
sérissaient que ça soit en primaire en
6e en 3e en seconde ou en ou même elle a
fait des classes de terminal ce qui
m'avait interloqué c'est que en fait les
questions que posaient les enfants
étaient tous les mêmes vous avez connu
général de Gaulle ah et et et du coup
vous avez connu choulin bah oui j'ai
connu choulin j'ai connu général de Gaul
et vous avez connu vous avez connu
Hitler et elle répondait ah non si je
l'avais connu
[Musique]
jeurill